دون توقف يسارع الاوكرانيون الى تعزيز
قوتهم الناريه غرب باخموت والاستعداد لاي
هجوم محتمل نحو الجهه الوحيده المتبقيه
بيدهم والمؤديه الى المدينه المتواليه
خلفت التلال
نرافق وحده من المظليين اثناء تجهيزها
مضاد الدروع الاوكرانيه المطوره حديثا هذا
لمواجهه الاليات الروسيه في حال تقدمها
نحوهم
سلاح فعال ضد الدبابات نراقب اهدافنا عبر
هذه الشاشه ونصيبها عن بعد حوالي خمسه
كيلومترات ونستطيع التحكم بالصاروخ
وتوجيهه
افراد الوحده الذين شاركوا في عدد من
معارك جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا يرون في باخموت
واحده من اصعب المعارك لكنها تلحق خسائر
بشريه وماديه كبيره بالقوات المهاجمه كما
يقولون تظهر هذه اللقطات التي خصتها
الوحده بالجزيره تدميرهم احدى الاليات
الروسيه على اطراف بخموت
يحاولون ان ياتوا الى الجهه الغربيه ويقطع
طريق كوستانتينيكا لكننا مستعدون منعهم
والضرب دباباتهم
تكتيكاتهم العسكريه تشمل الدفاع عن بلدات
ومدن ما بعد ضخمه في حال وقوع الاسوء
بالنسبه اليهم عبر هذه الوسائل وغيرها
يحاول الاوكرانيون الحفاظ على سيطرتهم على
الجهه الغربيه لمدينه باخموت ومنع تقدم
القوات الروسيه اليها ومحاصره المدينه
بالكامل في ظل قرار القياده الاوكرانيه
مواصله القتال هناك
[موسيقى]
عبر بلده تشاسفيار يتواصل زحف الدبابات
كما المدرعات المحليه والغربيه نحو
المعركه المتواصله منذ اكثر من ثمانيه
اشهر فالبلده باتت اشبه بمعسكر للقوات
الاوكرانيه ومرضا لمدافعها حيث لا يهدا
القصف منها كما عليها
ورغم خطوره الاوضاع ما زال بعض السكان
يعيشون هنا
اصطحبتنا الى منزلها الواقعي عند خط النار
وكان الحال يحكي عن نفسه
[موسيقى]
الا تشعران بالخوف لبقائكما هنا
بالطبع نشعر بالخوف صحيح اننا نشعر بالخوف
لكننا مضطران للتعايش مع الوضع
بضع مئات اثر البقاء في البلده رغم الخطر
الشديد وباتوا يعيشون على مساعدات
المتطوعين املين الا يتدهور الوضع اكثر
لكي لا تلقى بلدتهم مصيرا مشابها لمصير
جارتها وان تصمد قواتهم هناك لئلا تسقط
رايتهم هنا حسن مسعود الجزيره غرب باغموت